what do you think I have a question then
what do you think how do you think
comedy looks after this where do you
think we go from here I don't know I
mean different theory I've never had
been where people are like people were
saying early like the comedy middle
class is gonna be [ __ ] like people
that are open my curse at work day jobs
we find cuz they can and then like
headliners will be okay I don't know if
anyone's gonna have to stop doing
stand-up do you know what I mean like I
don't think anyone I don't know how many
clubs are gonna shut down completely but
so you just headline fewer clubs I guess
well yeah I mean there's few there's
less money coming in I mean we have
traveling I don't know yes I think that
there will be less money but I don't
think it'll be you can no longer be a
comedian I think you can still make a
living doing it it'll it for some people
it will be a worse living but I don't
know I was supposed to start a show in
New York like a one-man show
may 5th Wow and had the theater
everything and then just gone do you I
mean I can't help but it's interesting
because you can find an airplane yep but
you can't sit in a venue you know well
that's what the the I've read yesterday
I think 50% of Ja like hospitality and
live events is down 50% employment so
half the people are unemployed but then
there's I've read another thing where
they there are venues like 300 Cedars
are basically saying to headliners like
headliner headliners like there's a
place called City Winery in New York
there's like eight of them there's like
in different cities it's basically a
live music venue or performance venue
they they base is said to headliners
like we could have 80 people in here and
you can charge whatever you want so
there are there are certain acts that
are thinking like I could search 300
bucks a ticket right and if it's 80
people
that the grouse is 24 grant right maybe
I can walk with 14 or what you know I
mean like something or you get the hold
or like it if you if you have fans that
can pay a lot of money you could do
shows tomorrow right you just have to
charge people a lot of money Yeah right
to in order to enforce social distancing
you're gonna but I once there's a let's
say there's a vaccine in a year I think
it goes more or less how it was I don't
like you know I seem right what do you
think I think so I think yeah I think
you get back to I mean I think you know
some of the clubs are opening up they
had a hundred people in 125 people in
the ones that in Oklahoma City and and
in Salt Lake City I just wonder if
they're gonna you know if that works I
can't see them after you know a couple
of weeks not sliding in an extra table
here they're you know we're like yeah I
mean a little bit of that's gonna happen
so you're gonna win Christ that there
will there be raids or will people I I
had the thought and I and I'm I'm fairly
sure I'm not certain about much in kovat
hmm there's not gonna be another
lockdown meaning once this lockdown is
over they're not gonna be able to do
another one right I don't I just don't
think people are gonna go for it yeah I
don't know if because I think now I
think people are like okay we did we
tried to flatten the curve yeah I think
now too many people just don't know what
to believe there's that I also think
even if there's a second wave in the
fall I think you're not gonna be able to
shut the country down I just don't I
think people are gonna be like nah man
we did it we gave we did three months
right of a worse life for almost
everybody I have a worse life everybody
it's a worse life right it's more a
different life yeah it but I think for a
lot of it's people are even I'm not that
social I still wish I could go work and
deuce to socialize right yeah I don't
think people are gonna go for it again I
think it'll be some of it on the right
will be we don't believe you and some on
the left will be like ah come on man
like we did it once
the economy is on life-support yeah
and so that's the I think that this if
there is a second wave I think it's
gonna be every man for himself I think
people are just gonna be like there you
go you and Shaw I'm always self what do
you think you like that Nick I don't
know if you you could completely
quarantine and not leave your house if
that's the fear if you're older that's
my mom's 87 yeah and I've had to like
yell at her and be like look you stay
home like well I know know you're 87
there's a if you get Kovac over 80
there's a 20% chance yeah that's a
frickin Rappaport right there yeah now
having said that there was a guy show
the picture of the guy who was at Miami
Music Festival and he almost he was
ripped it was on BuzzFeed news
he was yoked and then he and then he got
was it Ehrenburg this guy was on
steroids wow that's funny I didn't think
about that
I'm so naive yeah you probably if you
don't get steroids for a while
especially during this thing then you
gotta know if you do Miami yeah I think
this I went to high school with this kid
named Chris I think is that him what's
this guy's name
yeah that God is he done any steroids
left I've seen this kind of [ __ ] and it
if you completely stop lifting you don't
you don't eat you dehydrate so my kid
can so he was in he was in like
intubated for six weeks and he thought
it was a week Wow yeah he's like said to
the nurse I'm about like a so it's been
a week she's like a week you've been
here six weeks living off the frickin
government's dime this bastard just
laying there in a coma bro wake up man
bro yeah you gotta get back out of your
straps at bro he went from you to me
basically [ __ ] poor guy holy o nation
dude it was 26 percent of his body
weight in six weeks that's it's a lot
yeah but that's what I was saying
it's gonna be every man for himself I
was joking on the way over here that
there should be you know like the NFL
Combine yeah that should just be like if
you can run the 40 and under 8 seconds
you're good to go like you can you're
good do you like people on the starting
line with their bug I jump just like are
you fit enough he'll be all right the
chances are you're gonna be fine
yeah that anti but I cuz I truly don't
believe they're gonna be able to do it
again I don't think I think enough
businesses will be like I'm not gonna
have a business yeah I think there's
like a quarter businesses are [ __ ]
anyhow well a lot of people are
operating on the DL I go to a trainer
and see a trainer on the DL you know
like and it's you know they have a
curtain in front of the you know yeah
right knee so nobody could see yeah I
know people are getting like secret
haircuts back-alley haircuts yeah I went
got one yesterday at a garage over in
Reseda Simon up Twitter really yeah
that's so funny so I'd have finish it up
myself a little bit she go she didn't do
bad didn't do great but good evening
good afternoon and other times thanks
for watching that video you just saw I
mean it was okay but the next video you
can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one